qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens
ah ça c'est une vaste question moi
personnellement je prends tout le temps
le livre plutôt leur qui pose problème
en général et votre frère ils en pensent
quoi tient sur la même longueur d'onde
mais tout un truc quoi on est d'accord
ils sont assez efficaces je regrette un
peu qu'on ait changé tous les abribus et
votre frère il en pense quoi tu as
raison quoi c'est en tout le même
concept si tu préfères c'est vrai que
bon on est toujours charlier c'est
toujours l'usagé qui pénalise et agneaux
ses soeurs bon 12e
il se vend 2 et de tma avec dépit
ils sont excellents je les utilise peu
parce que j'habite le quartier
oui mais moi j'ai trop fort mis d'accord
et bonne forme en pense quoi
ma soeur je te laisse plus qu est ce que
vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens monsieur personnellement je
suis très satisfait donc je prends le
métro en dehors des heures de points
d'accord et votre frère ils en pensent
quoi valider notre pointe
oui
merci beaucoup